quelques instants seulement après le
rejet d'émotions de censure à
l'Assemblée et des groupes de plusieurs
centaines de personnes plutôt des jeunes
se forment des convergent dans
différents points un régime est en fin
de course ah mais ça sent ça sent oui la
fin d'un régime oui c'est la fin du
régime de Monsieur Macron de ce
gouvernement qui ne tient plus que par
un fil aux quatre coins du pays les
mêmes images
des feux de poubelles et des barricades
ici à Rennes j'attends du président de
la République qu'il
apaise le pays nous sommes dans une
situation de crise majeure vous la
souhaitez vous la dissolution ou pas j'y
réponds je vous dis ce que les français
demandent ce que je demande ce n'est pas
forcément la dissolution c'est le
retrait de cette réforme des retraites
elle doit être retirée au plus vite on
est en train de se créer pour une
dizaine de milliards d'euros c'est
l'équilibre de c'est un peu la fin de
enfin sur les retraites c'est un peu là
où on en est aujourd'hui pour une
dizaine de milliards d'euros la plus
grande crise sociale de ces 10 dernières
années et la plus grande crise politique
de ces peut-être 20 ou 30 dernières
années ça ça n'en vaut pas le coup ce
qu'il faut ce qui est important c'est de
nouveau de retisser le lien avec les
Français parler aux Français expliquer
pourquoi nous avons fait cette réforme
la première ministre était engagée à
remettre sa responsabilité devant le
Parlement
et qu'elle a été de cette manière là
confortée par le Parlement c'est un
point qui est important et je le redis
parce que elle est confortée ce matin
vous céderez car vous ne tenez qu'à neuf
voix
vous céderez car deux Français sur trois
souhaitent votre départ vous céderez car
passer en force contre le peuple les
syndicats le Parlement relève d'une
folie on attend qu'il démissionne
Elizabeth borne je pense que c'est
inimaginable que Isabelle Borg puisse
rester après ce vote de défiance
moi aussi j'ai quelques mois à partager
que vos dernières interventions et
l'attitude de votre groupe ces dernières
semaines m'ont rappelées le premier
c'est duplicité tout ça est brouillon
mal fait et elle incarne désormais cette
défaite et elle va subir elle ce que je
suis en train de lire la violence de la
5ème république c'est-à-dire que ce
président qui a voulu cette réforme va
l'utiliser le mot Edel d'ailleurs comme
un fusible madame la Présidente panneau
avec votre groupe vous êtes des
représentants de la nation alors
respectez le résultat des urnes et les
votes au Parlement respecter nos
institutions et respecter enfin notre
démocratie une fois que le Conseil
constitutionnel se sera prononcé la loi
entre en vigueur à partir du 1er
septembre
de matinée au dépôt pétrolier de
Fos-sur-Mer j'ai de pierres
contre gaz lacrymogène
3 CRS sont sérieusement blessés non au
désordre à la bordélisation et je veux
le dire à ceux qui veulent mettre le
chaos
en utilisant les policiers comme
victimes de leur propre incurie vous
avez tout raté là-dedans la bataille de
l'opinion politique les concertations
inexistantes le passage devant
l'Assemblée nationale même un deal vers
eux avec une fausse opposition en
échange de quelques sorties d'autoroutes
avoir demain une Elizabeth borne avec
une moustache ou ça changera rien dire
bon ce sera la même politique la même
manière très certainement de gouverner
parce qu'en réalité c'est Emmanuel
Macron qui est responsable de cela et
c'est dans ce contexte que le Président
de la République s'exprimera demain à
13h sur France 2 et TF1 alors que
faut-il en attendre ces mots
suffiront-ils à calmer la colère et le
fait de laisser fuer comme on dit c'est
phrase que je donnais à l'instant pas de
dissolution pas dans maniement pas de
référendum c'est aussi une façon de dire
à tous les observateurs à tous les
Français n'attendaient pas de grands
chambardement
de ma part demain à 13h en direct